in Europe we take for granted that the
food on our plate is safe what does that
really mean over a hundred thousand
people across the countries of the EU
perform official controls of some 20
million food operators in the European
Union at farms at motor controls during
transport at slaughterhouses at food
industry at restaurants and supermarkets
these controls check for any risk to
human health food is inspected to look
for pesticides chemical residues
microbial contamination poor hygiene and
proper labeling poor refrigeration
animal welfare and fraud there is a
system of traceability which enables
products to be followed along the food
chain from its origin a European network
of national food safety authorities
deals swiftly with any food safety risks
across the whole European Union Europe
has the highest food safety standards in
the world the European Commission works
to make sure that the food that arrives
on 500 million Europeans plates is safe
food 500 million reasons to keep it safe
you